Hello!
See you today
to know how to park in the back of your hand.
This can be requested on the day of your exam.
You start by identifying the place
that you want to park on.
Before you slow down and stop,
put your turn signal
on the right to indicate that you have performed 1.
Turns on the reverse gear,
the recoil lights will light up
and the vehicles behind it will include
that you wish to.
I remind you that for any,
you have no priority,
so if 1 vehicle arrives,
you have to stop and let it go.
Stop at the level of the 2nd parked car
next to the chosen location.
You must be about 1m away from the vehicles that are already
stationed.
Remember to look around and check your nails
dead.
1 time the clear path,
slowly retreats
until you have the fire
front right of the car
parked to the right of the chosen location,
through your rear passenger window.
At that time,
stop and see if you're going to get in the way
or surprise 1 other user.
Indeed,
in Portuguese,
At the end of your vehicle,
it will deport to the left.
Turn the steering wheel fully while gently backing up.
Performs all controls
with the help of direct vision and your mirrors.
Keep going backwards
until your vehicle is parallel to the
line delimiting the square
or to the car parked next to you.
When this is the case,
stop and straighten your wheels by backing up.
The steering wheel
then back up slowly to park
in the middle of the site.
Don't forget to put the handbrake in neutral.